so you are celebrating a major Milestone
it's been 20 years since you started as
an ambassador for Unicef that's
incredible how did you end up 20 years a
long time what was there something that
happened in your life that made you want
to be a part like why UNICEF yeah well
in 2000 I lived in South Africa for
three months and I was filming I was
filming but I had a very small part in
this in this movie so I would I would go
volunteer in like townships and
children's hospitals and when I got back
to LA I had such a hard time
assimilating like the person that I
discovered there which was this you know
very
um uh empathetic uh compassionate and
you can't unsee certain things person of
service like that's I realized that
that's serving other people is what
fulfilled me and when I came back I went
through a really hard time a depression
because I was like uncharmed living in a
house in Beverly Hills you know driving
a BMW and I had just seen such hardship
and there was a lot of guilt in that
yeah and my mom said to me because she
was a huge fan of unicef's life-saving
work and did trick-or-treat for Unicef
when she was a kid and then I did it she
said you should call UNICEF and so in
2003 they they appointed me as an
ambassador and I've been able to travel
to Angola Africa two years after the
peace treaty was signed for the longest
civil war in the history of of the world
um India six months after the tsunami to
see how UNICEF was helping communities
rebuild
Kosovo where I learned about
um really the disparity in income and
how poverty impacts a child's
development and future obviously um yeah
yeah and then recently I went to Egypt
where my focus was on young girls and
um there's still some some practices in
the Egypt uh like female genital
mutilation that UNICEF with with the
government is really trying very hard uh
to to ban so so it's really just very
fulfilling
um hard work but important work and I
feel very blessed that I am still able
to be a person of service yeah I mean
it's it's the most incredible thing
right because you're super blessed in
your life and you get these
opportunities but to use that Spotlight
and for someone that might you know like
oh I love her and oh my God she's into
that what does that mean like you know
what I'm saying it is a very cool thing
to use that Spotlight so thank you for
doing that
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
I'm going home
[Music]